Heutzutage ist es bei den Jugendlichen so, wenn man keine Jordans hat, dann gehört man nicht zu den coolen.
Die Jungen profilieren heutzutage damit Zugehörigkeit.
Ich studiere IT an der ZHW.
Ich arbeite nebenbei als Junior Software Developer.
Ich bin Reseller und verkaufe alles, was mir so in die Hände kommt.
Reselling kennt man hauptsächlich von Schuhen.
Aber ich mache das mit Uhren, Wasser, Kleidern, Accessoires... alles mögliche.
Überall wo ich sehe, dass man daran Geld verdienen kann, versuche ich mich hineinzusteigern.
Das Absurdeste was ich jemals verkauft habe ist Wasser.
Virgil Abloh hat mit Evian eine Flasche selbst designt.
Die konnte man für 2,90.- CHF im Laden kaufen.
Ich habe sie danach für 40.- CHF weiter verkauft.
Ich hatte schon immer einen Flair für den Handel.
Es hat bereits früh angefangen mit iPods auf Ricardo kaufen.
Dann habe ich sie gebraucht und danach teurer verkauft etc.
2011 kam ich dann zu Sneakers.
Der teuerste Schuh ist der Red Oktober von Kanye West.
Man konnte ihn für 200 Dollar kaufen.
Jetzt kann man ihn für 4000-8000.- CHF kaufen.
Der MCA kostet 2000-3000.- CHF.
Dieser ist unter 2000.- CHF ziemlich schnell weg.
Virgil Abloh ist der Designer von Off-White.
Er ist mittlerweile der erste Schwarze welcher Head-Designer von Louis Vuitton ist.
Er hat gemeinsam mit NIKE diesen Schuh herausgebracht.
Dieser ist 2000-3000.- CHF wert.
Ich hatte das Glück an einem Event Virgil abzufangen ...
... ich zog die Schuhe aus und sagte zu ihm:
«Hey Virgil, do you want to sign your sickest shoes?»
Er machte seine Unterschrift drauf und gab sie mir zurück.
Für mich sind diese Schuhe etwas spezielles weil der Designer darauf unterschrieben hat.
Nicht einfach irgendeine Person.
Ich würde ihn nicht einmal für 10'000.- CHF verkaufen.
Ich habe dieses Erlebnis mit dem Designer gehabt, es gibt nichts besseres als das.
Der Reiz ist, dass man einen Schuh trägt, den niemand anderes hat.
Und wenn er limitiert ist, dann wissen andere, dass er sehr teuer war.
Oder dass du etwas gemacht hast, um an diesen Schuh ranzukommen.
Jeder möchte etwas besseres haben als der andere.
Damit profilieren sich die Jungen heutzutage.
Früher musste man auf den Websiten nachschauen was die Leute mögen.
Wenn man heutzutage den richtigen Instagram-Seiten folgt,
wird man jeden Tag geupdatet was gerade gehyped wird.
Man sieht wie die Leute in dem Kommentaren auf neue Releases reagieren.
Oder irgendein Star trägt einen Schuh, die Leute ticken aus und wollen ihn dann auch kaufen.
Weil die Nachfrage grösser ist als das Angebot steigt der Preis.
Das Resellen funktioniert bei mir so:
Off-White stellt zum Beispiel einen Schuh Online und ich kaufe ihn dann schnell genug für 220.- CHF.
Wenn der Schuh ankommt kontrolliere ich ihn zuerst.
Danach schreibe ich den Schuh in meine Liste ein.
Dann sieht man das Datum vom Einkauf, das Modell und Grösse.
Der Zustand bedeutet Dead Stock, das heisst dass er ganz neu ist.
Wenn er einen anderen Zustand hat, dann würde 8/10 oder 9/10 schreiben.
Dann schreibe ich noch den Einkaufspreis ein.
Dann gebe ich den potentiellen Wert fürs resellen ein.
Das wäre bei diesem Schuh 2100.- CHF.
Die meisten Sneakers auf dem Graumarkt sind auf Social Media.
Der Grund dafür ist dass dort 1000 Leute sind, die die gleiche Interessen haben und auch an Sneakermessen gehen.
Als wir damit anfingen,
die Sneakerness zu organisieren,
war es ein Get-together
all dieser Sneakerheads.
Mittlerweile kommen aber auch
Interessierte, um zu sehen,
was diese Sneakerheads
eben so machen
und warum sie zigtausende Franken
für Sneakers ausgeben.
# Willkomme i dr Schiinwält!
# Hier isch alles so nice!
Überall! 1'000 Menschen.
Die hat er vorhin gemeint, oder?
- Die gibt es nur zehnmal.
Das ist derjenige, den Travis
gekauft hat - für 35'000 Fr.
Unglaublich!
Sieh dir den Hund an!
Nochmals ein Hund. 200?
Das ist ja ... Puma.
- Ja.
Und dann dieser, Mann!
Auch dieses Rote - megaschön!
Ah, nice! Freddy Krueger.
Die kosten auch irgendwie 10'000 Fr.
Ist das der "Fuck Bush"?
# Das ist so sweet!
* Sanfte Hip-Hop-Musik *
# Ich bi nie nöd am Bügle,
nie nöd am Bügle.
nie nie nie nie nöd am Bügle.
# Ich bi nie nöd am Bügle,
nie nöd am Bügle.
schaffe alles, Motherfucker!
# Ich bi nie nöd am Bügle,
nie nöd am Bügle.
nie nie nie nie nöd am Bügle.
Da muss ich raten,
welcher der Fake ist, oder?
Das ist der Fake.
- Nein.
Das ist der Fake,
das ist der Original.
Crazy!
- Hast du das Video gesehen?
Ja, ich habe das Video gesehen.
Knallhart im HB zersägt.
Sie wollten damit
ein Statement setzen.
Also zerstörten sie den Schuh ganz.
Ich finde die Idee lustig.
Das sollte man
vielleicht öfters machen.
Es ist
eine ziemlich schwierige Frage
bezüglich
der Nachhaltigkeitsgeschichte usw.
Da gibt es schon Trends,
bei denen sich die Leute fragen:
"Ist das wirklich nötig?
Ich habe eigentlich genug."
Als Individuum ist es schwierig,
grosse Veränderungen zu machen.
Klar, können wir anfangen,
aber von der Politik
und den grossen Brands
sollten stärkere Zeichen kommen.
Es ist zwar gut für mich, dass die
Leute für Schuhe viel Geld ausgeben.
Ich selber
würde sie für mich nicht kaufen.
Aber ich verkaufe sie.
Was ich hier noch habe,
ist ein Jordan von Travis Scott.
Travis Scott
ist ein US-amerikanischer Rapper.
Der Schuh kam für 190 Fr. raus.
Er ist sehr limitiert.
Darum kostet er jetzt
2'000 bis 2'300 Dollar.
Neben den Schuhen habe ich
auch die Müesli von Travis Scott.
Sie kamen nur in Amerika raus
und waren entsprechend limitiert.
Und der Retailpreis
lag um die 40 Dollar,
was auch schon ziemlich viel ist.
Der Resellpreis
liegt bei 100 bis 150 Dollar.
Also etwas Gewinn
liegt da immer noch drin.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
# Murda on the beat
so it's not nice.
# For this life, I cannot change.
# Hidden Hills,
deep off in the main.
# M&M's, sweet like candy cane.
# Drop the top, pop it, let it bang,
pop it, pop it.
# For this life, I cannot change.
# Hidden Hills,
deep off in the main.
# M&M's, sweet like candy cane.
# Drop the pop, pop it, let it bang,
pop it, pop it.
# Drop the top, play hide and seek.
# Jump inside,
jump straight to the lake.
# Take a sip, feel just how I be.
Wir sind ein bisschen der Feind
der Sammler,
weil sie halt nicht
an ihre Sneaker herankommen.
Aber sie sind auch
ein bisschen selber schuld,
weil sie sich nicht genug Mühe
geben, an die Schuhe heranzukommen.
* Hip-Hop-Musik *
# Z'vil Empathie
laht e Nigga slippe.
# Worldlife muess no viel lehre.
# Nimm mini Kindness
nie für Weakness.
# Wil d'Limbs sind scharf
wie ir inch Era.
# Sie säged ich heg mich veränderet
# aber ich bi immer
no dr gliich Nigga.
# En z'grosse Hunger
isch mis Handicap.
# Sobald's lauft
wend sie dich kenne.
Ich nutze sozusagen
einfach den Moment aus.
* Sanfte Popmusik *
Der Konsum in unserer Gesellschaft
ist ... ähm ...
... abnormal hoch.
Wir geben viel zu viel Geld aus
für Sachen,
die man nicht wirklich braucht.
All dieses Zeug
müssen wir hinterfragen.
Wo kommen meine Kleider her?
Wo kommen meine Unterhosen her?
Ja, alles.
Es muss alles hinterfragt werden
und nicht nur das,
was ich mache.
Ich will mich einfach
in der Gesellschaft eingliedern
und meinen Beitrag dazu leisten,
dass sich unsere Welt verbessert.
Aber ich habe keine Idee,
wie man das ändern könnte.
Darüber habe ich mir noch nicht
wirklich Gedanken gemacht.
# These bitches want Nikes.
# They looking for a check.
# Tell em it ain't likely.
# Said she need a ring like Carmelo.
Ich habe mir vor zwei Jahren
ein Limit gesetzt,
bei dem ich mir gesagt habe:
"Ich kaufe mir keinen Schuh mehr,
der mehr als 500 Fr. kostet."
Dieses Limit habe ich einmal
bei einem Dior-Sneaker gebrochen,
aber sonst ...
Seit zwei Jahren
bin ich sozusagen clean.